[Musique]
bonsoir les petits enfants gros ours et
moi nous sommes bien contents et vos
mamans aussi vous leur avez souhaité
hier une très belle fête et ça leur a
fait très plaisir vous savez au oui ce
joli la fête des mamans nounours va voir
si petit louis et mirabel sont bientôt
prêt à se mettre au lit j'y fonce patron
europe et revient vite me
car nous devons encore allez voir
beaucoup d'autres petits enfants ou un
patron
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
apport aux caves est formidable cette
soupe
moi je crois bien que les colombes ça
mange des graines et les jours mais il
ya une petite colombe
mais enfin gentil a dit il c'est que
vous mais moi tu as vraiment contente
qu'elle a dit que les colons c'est très
gentil et excité une magnifique surpris
et content je veux te faire sa part
c'est trop les enfants souhaitent
trouves tu vas qu on lui fait à manger à
la colombe à duke
je crois qu'il vaut mieux lui donner des
grèves tu vois bien mirabel oui maman à
dire il faut aussi lui donner
moi je vais l'appeler célestine mais non
on va lui trouver un beau nom bionaz m
on va le lui trouver dans le
dictionnaire d'un jeune qui n'y voyons
p'tit louis un dictionnaire c'est un
livre où il y à tous les maux et tous
les noms ouais
voyons voir ou petit lion va voir un là
ouh là bonjour les bouchons sur la
cheminée
bien sûr bien tu veux que je suis
étourdi en voilà un
colombes il faut chercher à à ses
ouailles on a b c
coco coco colo à voilà voilà
colombe banlieue de paris s'est pas noyé
quand l'on bay les deux camps l'ont
billes bris
tu as nika petite colombe sait générer
alors que l'on bat mais oui une colombe
à c'est très bien et bien columba nous
te disons bonne nuit car il est à peine
8 hollande a connu une manche aller va
vite rejoindre l'iss nous est ce que je
touchais pour voir mes grands enfants à
demain beaune et nuits collombat
[Musique]
et vous aussi mes petits amis faites
comme petit louis et mirabel et comme
collombat allez vite vous couchez
embrasser bien fort vos parents au port
à te voilà nounours en route car nous
sommes un peu en retard ce soir là voilà
papon mains nues les enfants à demain
demain
[Musique]
en haut